nous sommes ici pour notre événement
futur at 6 mx le troisième que l'on
organise et qui présente des activités
de liberté systemx et plus exactement
qu'est ce que l'ingénierie numérique des
systèmes dans ce cadre là il s'agit de
comprendre le travail que fait un
ingénieur dans ce domaine du numérique
pour concevoir développer valider et
tester l'ensemble de ses nouveaux
produits qui incluent de plus en plus de
numérique
une idée simple un produit est
compétitive soit facile et moins cher
soit parce qu'il est meilleur et il est
meilleur parce qu'il apporte quelque
chose de nouveau aux clients et cette
innovation
elle résulte une invention mais elle
résulte aussi d'un progrès technique et
ce progrès technique il se construit par
une collaboration recherche industrie et
donc l'innovation c'est les gens qui
travaillent ensemble pour un plus
apporté au client le défi diète et
systémique et de s'insérer au sein du
panneau de saclay sur cette dimension
engineering systems en s'appuyant à la
fois du côté académique sur la nouvelle
université paris saclay et du côté
industriel sur l'ensemble de
l'écosystème cas constituer le pôle de
compétitivité systematic n'arrive ainsi
avec ses deux premiers à les faire
travailler ensemble et aborder des
problématiques qui sont tirées par le
marché sur des cases usage écrits sont
souvent transversale par rapport à
différents marchés que sont le monde du
transport le monde la sécurité le monde
des télécoms où deux mondes de la cyber
sécurité par exemple
paris saclay a vocation à devenir le
centre français et même le centre
européen de rencontres entre les
entreprises l'industrie la recherche
fondamentale la recherche appliquée dans
un seul lieu dans un périmètre de 10 ou
15 km on retrouve des grands centres de
recherche industrielle les meilleures
écoles et universités françaises et des
centres de recherche appliquée à la
pointe du progrès et donc ce dialogue
cette proximité géographique ce fait que
ces gens qui travaillent sur les sujets
voisins peuvent se rencontrer fait qu'on
y fera plus d'invention plus
d'innovation et donc qu'on construira
l'avenir économique du pays